- Please take a seat in the yellow chair.
- OK, the yellow one.
We said the yellow one
for Mr. Thuram, and the purple for Ritza.
I think Mr. Thuram is impressed.
You can tell?
- Can I call you Lilian?
- Yes, Lilian is fine.
Yeah, I can call him Lilian,
I feel great.
That's made my day.
Thank you so much for agreeing to do this.
I was so thrilled to think
that I could write a message
on your foundation's website
and have a conversation
with Mr. Gauthier
your foundation's director
who is here with us today.
I am extremely honored and super stressed
I'll be honest
to interview you today,
and, really, very honored to discuss
the work that you've
accomplished with the foundation.
So, thank you again.
And I'm going to begin
without further introduction
with why you set up this foundation.
What led you to set it up?
Well, first off, hello.
It's always best to greet people.
- That's a good start.
- Exactly.
In fact, it began
at a dinner, when I was a soccer
player in Barcelona in 2008.
There was a man next to me,
a gentleman of a certain age.
He asked me questions, saying:
"What are you
going to do when you're older?"
Because I was at the end of my career.
So, he thought soccer was great,
but it was for children.
"So, what are you going
to do when you're older?"
And the answer
I gave him was childish, I said
"Well, when I'm older,
I'm going to change the world."
He said, "How will you change the world?"
I said, "I would like to go into schools
and discuss racism, sexism,
and homophobia
to tell people you aren't born racist,
you become it.
In fact, it's cultural conditioning."
People often aren't aware of this.
He said, "OK, what does that mean?"
I said, "For example,
tell me what black people are like?"
And so he replied,
"OK, black people are like this or like that."
I said, "That is how racism starts."
When we think we know what someone
will be like based on the color of their
skin, their sexuality, or their gender.
And then I gave him a few examples
and when he left he said
"Mr. Thuram,
I'm older than you.
You ought to know
we can't change the world."
And a few weeks later,
my telephone rang
It was that same man,
and he said, "You know what?
You have already changed someone."
And that's what gave me the idea
to set up a foundation
because he was the president of a...
of DDB Spain.
They're a leading advertising agency.
And so, little by little,
I set up this foundation.
And we have been visiting
schools for 10 years now
in France, and in other countries.
We're always trying to
challenge public perception.
The basic premise of the foundation
is "you aren't born racist,
you become one."
That's the idea behind
Education against Racism.
You present this as part of your personal
story as something
instinctive, a feeling.
Have you researched this premise?
How did you get to it?
Is it just experience
or have there also been studies
that support this point of view?
First, it comes from a lived experience
because I was born
in the Antilles, in Guadeloupe.
I came to Ile-de-France in 1981
when I was nine years old.
And I always say
I became Black when I was nine.
It seems surprising, but you become black.
You become black in the eyes of the other.
And the really interesting thing is that
when you become black,
you understand that it's a trivial thing.
It's a very negative thing.
Some of my classmates
named me after a cartoon...
You are very young,
so you wouldn't know it.
Sorry, I'm showing my age.
It was called...
They called me "la Noiraude."
Does anyone know
the cartoon "La Noiraude?"
- Yeah
- Oh yeah.
You read that too? OK.
But, that's scary, they're really young.
He's been saying,
"They're really young" for 20 minutes.
- I think that's really shocked him.
- It's extremely disconcerting.
Well, there was a really stupid black cow.
It makes you wonder
why the black cow was stupid
while the white cow was very intelligent,
and I really didn't understand at all.
And I remember I went home one day
and I asked my mum
why black people are viewed negatively.
And she gave me a very bad answer.
She said, "That's the way it is.
People are racist. That won't change."
And the thing with that was
that it meant that everyone was racist
and it was unavoidable.
So after that, I looked into it more
and spoke to some people.
and I also began to understand my own family better.
Because I started out
with a lot of questions.
As I said, I'm from the Antilles.
We are a slightly non-conventional family.
We were five children
from five different dads.
And none of them were around.
So I also had to ask myself
why is my family like this?
Because I was faced
with another way of being a family
in the Ile-de-France,
and so I came across
the history of slavery
which was a very
unsettling story
but after I did some research
and I understood that
it was not a power relationship
that white people or black people wanted
but above all,
it was a concept.
It was about economics.
It was an economic construct.
And economic
constructs involve domination.
Through domination,
you create a discourse.
So, we created a whole discourse
categorizing people
according to their skin color.
And this hierarchy
still exists in today's societies.
It is exactly the same thing
between men and women.
It's because of a political construct
that our society
still teaches men to think
they are superior to women.
That's why—this comes from
your personal story, again
I saw that the foundation
relies on
a committee of scientists,
and anthropologists, etc.
Have they helped back up the statement
"you aren't born racist, you become it."
or have they researched other things?
In fact, first of all,
We have all of the knowledge
needed to understand racism.
Because, effectively,
even the subjects of racism,
don't generally understand
what is happening
or what causes it.
So, I think it's very important
to include intellectuals
and they help
to enrich my own way of thinking as well
so that when
I'm talking to children in particular
I can be quite specific.
For example, we have Mr. Yves Coppens
and Ms Françoise Héritier,
who has sadly passed away.
And there are psychologists
as well, which is very important for me
because, more than anything else, racism
is often an unconscious feeling.
And we don't control it.
So, it's very interesting
to look at every aspect
to understand this question.
The particularly interesting thing
about the foundation's perspective
it is the idea of unlearning.
There's a great literary movement
lots of people have read
Sapiens in particular
which aims to give us
a different perspective
on the history, or
the hierarchization
according to race, of man/woman.
It's all forms of discrimination.
Because the foundation deals with
every type
of discrimination and equality...
...the caste system.
So unlearning is an interesting approach.
How do you start?
Who does it start with? How far can it go?
Unlearning is a major project.
But first you must
recognize that categories exist.
We have created
categories throughout history.
If you are aware of that,
that's a good start.
For example, men/women,
that's a category, it's not harmless.
If you are a man
you need to know that
you're likely to think...
I'm not talking about the men in here.
I'm talking about other men.
You might think that you are
superior to women.
And women can also
subscribe to a similar logic
by thinking that there are
things that are not for them.
And it's similar with
the color of your skin
There are associated categories.
And I think that to begin with
if you are aware of that,
you know that we don't
have the same experience of society,
We don't describe history in the same way.
For example, whether you are called
western or non-western
that also changes the way history is told.
I use examples with
the children, obviously.
You know that this isn't true.
I ask the children
"Do you know Christopher Columbus?"
The children say, "Yes, what about him?"
I say, "Are you sure you know who he is?"
They say, "Of course, Mr. Thuram."
I say, "Who is he?"
"He discovered America."
I say, "Really?
OK, kids, let's play a little game.
"Imagine you're in the classroom
and someone opens the door
and says I've discovered the classroom."
The children say, "That's not right."
I say, "But why not?"
They say, "We we're already there."
And I say, "But when Columbus
reached the Americas,
there were 80 million Native Americans."
And they respond, "Oh yeah."
But it's how we tell the story.
And that's very interesting, and if
you're not aware of this conditioning
you can't understand
the mechanisms of racism.
If, for example, you haven't heard of
the Code Noir [Black Code]
you can't really understand racism.
Who here has heard of the Code Noir?
The majority, I see, that's very good.
That can go on the website,
if it goes like that.
- In fact...
- That will be edited in the video.
It's very interesting because
the Code Noir is really interesting.
Being from the Antilles
I had to know the Code Noir,
it was like the civil code for
how black people were treated
during slavery.
So, the Code Noir started
in 1685 and ended in 1848.
And so you can see that black people
weren't considered to be human beings.
They were seen as property.
But, because that lasted such a long time
it ended up being a habit.
If you don't understand that
the Code Noir ended in 1848
and that's extremely close to our times
you won't understand
the mentalities we see today.
For example, I often say that
my grandfather was born in 1908
60 years after the abolition of slavery,
because there as well
we think of slavery as not really being
connected to us.
But that means that I was born
a few generations after slavery
so if we don't recognize that
we can't understand.
If you don't know the
Code de l'indigénat [indigenous peoples' code]
it's exactly the same thing.
The Code de l'indigénat, is how
they managed people in the colonies.
And that ended in the 1950's.
And in the 1950s
there were still classes for
ten-year-old children in school
which taught them there was a hierarchy
of people according to their skin color.
And white people were superior.
There's a gradation of color,
and black people
are the missing link between
monkeys and humans.
That's why, when I was a soccer player
fans would make
monkey noises at me.
They did not know this history
but to them,
making the link between black and monkey
seemed normal.
Really, they had learned that.
That's why I say
that it is very interesting
to understand history
so you can unlearn it.
To understand, in effect, how you work.
That is, how we interact
with each other, according to skin color
disability, or whether
we are male or female,
I mean there are, how can I say this...
Relationships that you
don't understand sometimes.
For example, here in France, in any case
there is always this color barrier.
People will say it's not true.
But it is. I mean if
we looked for diversity here
who would represent diversity?
For a French person?
Do you represent diversity?
You look diverse.
It's the same if we look for
someone from a visible minority.
That's you again. Sorry.
OK, but if we say visible minority
that means there's an invisible majority.
And who are the invisible majority?
White people.
So we have made something up
about native French people.
So, you are not native French.
I can sense it, I don't know why.
But we wouldn't class you as native.
You mustn't sit next to me.
This is just to show that
we don't really realize
but there is often
this barrier based on skin color.
And there is another way of seeing things.
And I think that the first thing
is to recognize that.
And then, little by little, we can heal.
The idea of becoming aware
and unlearning is interesting.
So my question to you is
—because it's called
"education against racism"—
what do you learn after that?
Because there's a risk of relearning
a model that, could become in...
20 or 40 years yet another failure.
Or what do you do to teach
a vision that is sufficiently broad
that you can impose it without any danger?
So, if we class ourselves
as a human beings
when writing history, that's interesting.
So we step outside the hierarchies,
because very often
when I talk to you about
Christopher Columbus,
you know the story.
There were many people.
But, the others didn't
really exist until we discovered them.
Or until we saw them.
I think it would be interesting
when talking about Columbus...
Who here, for example, has heard of
the Valladolid debate?
No one. It's very interesting to
understand that as well.
The topic in question was
"Do Native Americans have a soul like us?"
Because that's what's interesting.
Showing that these questions of domination
existed in the past and also exist today.
What does European society
think about the world?
Does the world belong to everyone?
Who does the world belong to?
- It's a good question.
- It is.
But it doesn't belong to everyone,
believe me.
I don't want to spoil the mood.
But it does not belong to everyone.
There are some people who just
have to do what other people have decided
to do, and follow them.
Because there is a model to follow.
And it was mostly us
who established that model.
And again today, we end up
thinking that we are dominant
and it's right for us to be dominant
because we're better than the rest.
It's always this trick of...
changing your perspective,
because very often
we begin by thinking that we are
at the center
and that we are right, us.
But we often don't have a global
vision of world history.
But I think that history
should be told differently.
Yes, told differently. OK.
I'm going to explore
the foundation's work a bit more.
I saw that there were four pillars
that make up your work:
equality, individuality,
education and remebrance.
Could you tell us a bit
more about each of those pillars?
How you handle them
within this idea of education.
How you approach them.
Well, the idea of being unique.
It seems silly, but
since the dawn of time
when we tell the story of racism,
sexism, or homophobia
we forget that every one of us is unique.
We box people in
according to skin color.
When we talk about people with black skin
it's, "black people
all work in the same way."
And when I'm with children
not the very young ones,
because the very young ones
are really pure anyway
but with the older ones.
When I ask the question
"Tell me what black people are like?",
there are some children who respond.
It's awful.
It's because, in their minds
these people don't exist as individuals.
They exist as a collective.
It's like if you said, in these schools...
"What are white people like?"
They say,
"Well, they're like everyone else."
That means they have characteristics of...
When I ask about Asians, they say
"they play ping-pong, they are yellow."
It's just to show that that exists.
It's the children who
grow up with ideas about color.
And that's interesting.
That's why I say
we really need to teach people
to understand that
every one of us is unique.
And when we talk, for example,
about French culture, because...
what is French culture?
Who is French here?
Everyone? I can't tell.
Listen... Because I can see
some people aren't listening
so, I thought...
Right, the majority, OK.
We're all agreed that
I am Antillean, I am French.
There are people who are Breton
or Alsatian
for whom French culture is complex.
But even in the Antilles,
we don't all have the same culture.
It's something personal.
And sometimes that unsettles me.
We would like to say
that there is a French culture
a French way of being.
And so we say, "you will need
to integrate into French culture."
But which one?
Which one?
The odds are already against you.
And so we need to come back to this:
every one of us has our own culture.
And we need to recognize that as well.
That's why I talk about individuality.
Because that is the problem of racism.
He is black, he is like this.
He is white, he is like that.
But that doesn't make sense.
That's a man, he is like this.
And I think it's really important
to develop that in children.
Then, remembrance...
remembrance is very important to me
because, once again
every one of us here is
the product of history.
The product of the past.
And we must remind children
that societies evolve
because there have always
been men and women
who have said no to injustice.
And I think it is very important
to recognize that.
Because people frequently say
"No, nothing changes."
Yes, things do change. I'm proof of that.
I told you that
my grandfather was born in 1908.
Things have changed because
there have always been people
who fought for freedom and equality.
And we tell the kids something essential
that freedom is won, it is not given.
And so, we must be properly
prepared to fight for this equality
so for me, remembrance is very important.
And then there is...
There was equality, individuality,
education. You've done lots.
Equality, yes. That seems obvious to me.
Often, when we talk to the children
about equality,
they really have a problem with
homosexuality, for example.
OK, and whatever their religion,
we come up against,
"Yeah, but they're not like us."
But, when I say, "So, kids
can one person
have more rights than another
in our society?"
... they say, "No."
"Can an individual have fewer rights?"
"No."
And I say, "OK, there you go.
That means you think
that a homosexual
is not a human being like us."
That's the problem with categories.
They mean that sometimes,
we don't see other people
as human beings like ourselves.
We see them through their religion
color, or sexuality.
So that's why, in my opinion, equality
is always very important.
And putting the human being
back at the heart of everything.
When we talk about the human being
it's actually easier
for the younger children.
OK. So I wonder, because...
In the organizations here in France
that represent minorities
and diversity and the minority
they are ensuring success,
helping them to achieve.
But the minorities, they...
Well, we're coming back to the
invisible majority and visible minority.
- No, no, but...
- I won't go back to that discussion...
we would need more time...
- No, but it's interesting because
the majority generally speaking,
people who make up the majority
because if belong to a minority
- they think... I don't know.
- I don't belong anywhere.
You've talked about minorities,
but what is really interesting,
is that people
who think they are the majority
think that they are more legitimate.
They wouldn't want to say it
but it's true.
I am part of the majority,
I am more legitimate.
I am part of the minority,
I must keep out of the way.
We mustn't form groups
in case it's a plot.
you never know...
Wait, what does that mean?
OK? Well, it's interesting.
Interesting in the sense that it's like a plot.
Right.
The front row are laughing at that.
Because we're in a group,
we're plotting.
You are plotting something.
I'm going to tell you
a quick story about "plotting".
Because very often
we don't realize.
When you are a so-called minority
and have dark-brown skin,
you are noticed...
when your body comes into the equation,
you are noticed.
Once, when I was
at with my soccer team
we were "in the green",
which is when you go to the hotel
before a match to relax and all that.
And so there was a big table
and we were having dinner
and my trainer arrived and said to us
"You blacks,
you're always together.
"It doesn't bother you,
you're always there together."
He said that to me in Italian.
I said, "Oh yeah, it's weird though,
there are 4 of us black people here,
and there are 15 white people
and we're in a group."
"And they're in a group there as well."
And the guy looked at us and then he left.
No, but it's interesting.
That's why I say that sometimes
there are even guys who think
"We can't be in a group.
They'll think we're plotting.
Let's split."
So, it's interesting.
It's funny you have
so many stories like that
both personal and from your research,
that you can tell the children.
Tell me, when you talk to the kids
what do you tell them are the keys
to getting on in society
to be successful, in whatever way?
Because unlearning
and relearning allows them
to better integrate in society
in the positive sense.
How do you help them go further,
to realize that there is a place
for them in society, a good place.
Well, that is the most important thing.
- Yes.
- Well, we call that
self-esteem.
It's what helps you get ahead in society.
And that's why it's
extremely important
to talk about racism in all its forms.
Why? Because when people
are subject to racism
it can affect their self-esteem.
That means I don't belong
or I feel inferior.
And so the idea is to say, yes
racism exists,
however, you need to understand
that you are not the problem
the others are.
So, when I was in Italy
people made monkey noises on the pitch.
I didn't doubt that there was a problem:
it was the fans.
And that is very important.
Besides, this is what works
best with children.
As soon as they understand it,
they say, "Oh, yeah."
and whatever the problem is,
"you're fat, you're..."
they know the other person
is the one with the problem.
Because otherwise you'd never cope.
And so, we also need to teach children
how far they should accept
having to disguise themselves.
Because, generally speaking, in life
all of us are made to wear
disguises sometimes.
The dominant category frequently
asks you,
either consciously or unconsciously
to resemble them.
For example, we'll talk about
disguising your accent.
Recently, I was at the house
of some journalists
and I said, "It's strange though,
"on the TV, it seems like
there's only one accent."
So there must be some
journalists who disguise themselves
who have Southern accents,
and who have been told
"Listen to your accent."
And so, he said,
"Oh yeah, that's true,
they did say that to me."
And one of them said,
"Yeah, I say 'shore' with an accent
so now I say 'coastline' instead."
And so it's very interesting.
But you need to know, for example
when you are called a minority
that's why it's very interesting
you're told
to disguise yourself sometimes.
Your behavior.
I don't want to shock anyone.
Even sometimes the barber.
For example, very often
women hide their frizzy hair.
Because, really, they look at
the rules of beauty
and they don't see themselves.
It's very interesting to think about that.
And to know how far you go.
For example, when I talk
about self-esteem
In the United States, they did
a test with dolls.
I don't know if you've heard of it?
Do you know about the black dolls
and the white dolls?
OK, you're not American,
so that makes sense.
Well, they did tests with children
they said:
"Look, which doll is the most beautiful?
"The prettiest? The naughtiest?"
And the children attributed
all of the negative qualities
to the black dolls.
And at one point they said to them
"But which doll looks like you?"
And then they panicked
because the children were black.
So, they had internalized the idea
that all bad things
were their color, and on the film
you can see they are upset.
Because they suddenly realize that—oh no.
That's why I say this is really serious
because, more than anything else,
racism is really dangerous.
Because you can internalize
a negative thought about yourself.
And I frequently say to the children,
"There are a lot of young
homosexuals who take their own lives.
Do you know why?"
And they say, "Yes, their parents."
No, it's because of us.
Because we're the ones who cause them
to think negatively about themselves.
And I say to them,
"The problem isn't homosexuality.
The problem is us."
So, we need grow up
thinking about that.
Is it normal that every one of us
has at some point driven people
to suicide with our behavior?
That's why I think
self-esteem is very important.
Because for all of us
it's what helps us get on in life.
If I was a soccer player
you have this idea that
you could do it too.
And you have this potential inside of you
which will help you get on.
And you really deserve it. Really, there
are so many things that come together.
And sometimes unconsciously.
And they push us, but there are children
who have a handicap from the start.
Because they've been told,
their sexuality, or where they're from...
for example, at the moment,
I have an exhibition
in the Delacroix museum
in the 6th arrondissement of Paris
and recently, there were some children
who had come from Sarcelle,
they had come to see it.
And so I said to them
"What do you think of this area?"
They said
"It's weird here...
everyone speaks really quietly."
"It's funny when they talk like that."
"And why do they dress like that?"
And I said, "Do you feel uncomfortable?"
They said, "It's not for us here."
And I said, "But the museum?"
They said, "Yeah, but listen,
this isn't our place."
That's the problem.
Lots of children grow up thinking
that they're not in the right place.
And its extremely dangerous.
They can't succeed.
And so the idea is to provide
the knowledge to change that.
You've mentioned what you were doing
at the Delacroix museum.
Any other things
you've done you'd like
to talk about in detail?
It's very interesting.
Are there other activities
you'd like to describe?
I'm looking at the time too
to make sure our friends
can ask questions.
Listen, at the moment we are working on
an exhibition, L'Orient [The East]
about the painter Delacroix,
and we're showing to what extent,
when you look at a painting
you need to place it
in its historical context.
Because Delacroix actually traveled
to the East, to Morocco and to Algeria.
And it also shows that this
version of the East is fascinating,
because, in fact,
when he paints,
the artist is also in
his own reality.
And it's not the true reality of the East.
We tell the children,
"if you're given information
or if you're looking at a work of art
you need to question it."
"You mustn't take it at face value."
And the images of women as well.
Really, when you see the paintings
the women are extremely sensual,
extremely erotic.
And they show that even then
women were boxed into that image.
And today, when you watch television,
or in bus shelters
there are still images of
very erotic women.
And should we be looking at them
without questioning this?
Because aren't women often shown
as treasure to be won?
And then there are also
several rooms where
we talk about disguises.
When we use disguises.
What are acceptable disguises?
Do we know, for example
that we can't use
dark brown skin as a disguise?
Some people think we can,
but we need to remember the history.
And it also shows that
there are some things you can't
overcome with a disguise.
Then there is a book called
"My Black Stars"
that I wrote a few years ago.
In fact, it was really important to me
because, I don't know
if it's the case here...
Not you, madam.
The two gentlemen there.
The first time—I can tell that
you're not French just like that....
the first time that you heard about
the history of black people
in your school curriculum, when was it?
In secondary school?
But what did they talk about?
OK, you can't just repeat the same things,
that's not how it works.
What is this history?
I wanted to say more about it.
No, but really,
we often don't realize this
but the first time we here about
the history of black people
it's through the history of slavery.
And actually, it's shocking.
When you are dark brown you say
"Damn, what happened next?
Where were they before?"
And so, I said to myself,
I have to write a book
that questions the public's perceptions.
Because if everyone is made to
come at it from that angle
that creates a way of seeing the world.
And so the idea was to show that there
were men and women
who could tell a
different version of history.
Because, again, we are all
the product of a history
that we've been told.
We can't escape that.
But sometimes we don't realize how much
this history actually
determines the way we think.
And so the idea is to question this
way of thinking, question history.
And to inform.
And the funny thing was, because when I...
I went on TV
journalists would say, "Mr. Thuram
I didn't know black people
had done so many things."
Because the violence is so pervasive.
Although I was pleased,
the violence is everywhere.
And I even remember children
saying to me in Togo:
"Yeah, I thought that black people
hadn't done anything before."
And so, it's essential
to tell their stories.
and, actually, when
you look at your school curriculum
there are very few men
or women who have done
extraordinary things.
What's more
there are also very few women
in the school curriculum.
That is very significant.
So, the idea is always to try
to broaden our knowledge
to change the way we think.
That little scroll.
I wanted to show you,
because once again
the idea is to question.
So, can you see this map?
There was a movement there.
Can you see the map or not?
They cheated.
OK.
In fact, there were,
I'm not going to name names,
some people have asked me to turn it over.
And I often say,
"have you ever seen a soccer ball?"
You've never seen
a soccer ball?
You have seen a soccer ball?
OK, thank you.
I need interaction
otherwise it doesn't work.
And the ball is round.
You can't say the ball is upside down.
However, as soon as we change our
way of looking at
the world, we're told, no
we need to correct it
because it is upside down.
Really, it's just questioning
our way of thinking about the world
and our customs.
And the traditional maps you're used to
often have Europe at the center
and this is not by chance,
and what's more
on traditional maps
I don't know if you know
they don't actually show the true
proportions of the continents.
The scale is not right.
And that is also very interesting.
So, in effect, it's fixed.
It's always the same.
And I think that we need to
look for the complexity in things.
And we often don't think about it
because we're not taught to do that.
And so, with the map,
the children are the same
they say, "that map isn't right."
And, my son said to me the first time,
"But, Dad, France isn't even on it.
That's not right."
Then when he saw how small
France was he said
"No, that's not really France."
He felt a little worse about himself.
And really, that's the point.
It's showing that, actually,
in our customs
the ones we're brought up with
there are some things
that are entrenched.
And they're really stupid things
like categorizing people based on
their skin color.
One day when my son, Fred
—my second son—was four or five
I said to him, "My love, tell me are
you the only black child in your class?"
And the kid said, "I'm not black, Dad."
And I thought
"He has a problem,
he doesn't accept his color."
"There's something there
that we need to work through."
I said, "Oh, you're not black?"
He said, "Well no, I'm brown."
I said, "Ah OK, but my dear,
what color are the
other kids in your class?"
He said, "They're pink."
But it's very interesting as
when I play the game with the kids
we're using categories
that aren't actually real.
Because you, you're said
to be what? Black?
I don't know, dark brown?
OK, there you go!
But why are you giggling, madam?
Because there are different
levels of black!
And that's what's interesting.
And I'll tell you another story
to really make you think
about these false categories.
One time, I walked into a bar
And a man there said, "Mr. Thuram,
a person of color was asking for you."
I said, "Oh? A person of color?"
"What color was he?"
And he said, "Damn,
Thuram doesn't understand me."
He said, "Well no,
he's a person of color!"
I said,
"Yeah, but was he yellow or red?"
And he just left. He gave up.
This is just to show that we often
"use person of color"
as if white wasn't a color.
But, these categories are significant.
They were created in the past
and they mean they are colored,
they are not like us.
They can't have the same rights as us.
It's never an accident
when we talk about us and them.
That means something.
It means some people are delegitimized.
They don't need the same rights as us.
That's it.
I'll ask one last question
as it's one p.m. and
I'd like to pass the
microphone to my colleagues.
When we were preparing the talk,
you said, "I'm not claiming to be the voice of truth,
I just want us to move forward together."
So, if we move forward together,
how can we help you?
How can we contribute?
And when I say we, I'm talking about
the people here, Googlers,
but also beyond that, how do you work
with people who aren't part
of the foundation?
Look, there's the foundation director,
if he can be of technical assistance,
or I don't know,
but for me the idea is for each of us
to be able to ask questions
about ourselves and the people around us.
Because really,
sometimes we don't ask questions
or sometimes we hear certain things,
and we don't call people out
by saying, "Listen, you can't say that."
"That needs to change, that's not right."
And we tend to think that
as individuals, we can't do anything.
But we can. Just paying attention
to your own behavior
and also having the courage
to confront your own prejudices.
Because some people say,
"No, I'm not prejudiced."
No, every one of us has prejudices
and prejudices are very important
for humans. Because we need to act fast.
They are thoughts...
so prejudices are sort of a
quick... they help us think quickly.
So, sometimes, that can cause us to do
stupid things.
So, pay attention. That's the first thing.
That's how you can help me.
- I'd be very happy to do that. Easily.
-Yeah, yeah.
It's your turn, my friends.
Does anyone have a question for...
But use the microphones
at the back, please.
So we can see you on the camera
when you ask a question.
OK listen, next time
you should go at the back.
The next time, you go at the back,
that's how it is.
- Hello, thank you for being here.
- Hello.
I had a question about
some French territories
that have accepted the cosmopolitan
aspect of their populations really well.
In particular, the island of Réunion
in the Indian Ocean.
Where many types of people come together
dark brown, Asian, Hindu, Pakistani...
And at the end of the day,
this mix works really well.
What are the lessons,
from your experience
and having discussed this in your talks
that we can learn from this island?
And how can we apply them
to change the mentality
of all French people?
OK, so first of all
what they have in Réunion
is a variety of skin colors
but even within this variety
of skin colors, there are hierarchies.
We mustn't deny that. Even in Réunion.
And the hierarchy will be
from the lightest to the darkest.
Because, once again,
this culture goes back a long way.
Then, I believe we need to encourage
young people in particular
to understand that society
is moving in the right direction.
Because it often seems
like things can only get worse.
And so we should always
encourage questioning.
And also seriously question people
from the dominant category.
To show that we need to accept diversity.
But, we already have diversity.
I mean, when you go to the station.
- Which station is near...?
- Saint-Lazare. - Saint-Lazare.
You can see diversity in the
train station.
Then, the dangerous thing
is the elite who want
to make us believe we have to like this
and talk about that. And I also think
it's bad... to make a change
we need to cut certain people off
on the television.
Because, actually
they incite hatred. Because when
I talk about hierarchy
when I talk about hierarchy,
according to skin color, for example,
that creates certain advantages
for the people at the top
but it also angers
the people who are subordinated.
And so that's why we need to work
to destroy these hierarchies
for a fairer society
and so that people
don't need to be so angry.
But, it is true that Réunion
is a good example to follow. There you go.
Because, actually, they also have
every religion
and things are fine.
But there are people who say
that Réunion is not French.
- In any case, they have a post code.
- Pardon?
He said a post code. It's true.
There you go.
- Hello, so, I'm Maria Streed,
- Hello.
Some of my colleagues and I founded
Women at Google,
which is a network for women
in Google—a global network.
I would like your opinion on
this type of inter-company network
because you were talking about
uniqueness, individuality
that let us organize events
for men and women
but also many events just for women.
I would like your opinion on this.
Well, personally, I think that's great.
Because sometimes we need
to talk to each other
I mean, really, when I talk about
every one of us being unique
that can also be problematic.
I won't lie.
So, it's very important to have times
where you can talk to each other
and discuss how you
are going to change things.
But there are also times
when you need to ask men along
so you can tell them this.
Because sometimes
there are things men don't understand.
Because we're not women.
It's true.
So, it's good to talk among yourselves.
To have discussions. But we often
tend to see that as a very negative thing.
Because we sometimes don't realize that
men do this a lot.
but they don't need to explain it
it happens very naturally, sometimes you
go and there are only men there,
but the men don't notice.
There you go.
So, it's a good thing.
First, congratulations on your work with
the foundation,
and for your two goals
against Croatia as well.
That's for the younger people here.
That wasn't me, it was someone else.
You talked about the racist phenomena
that you came across in the stadiums
when you were in Italy,
I think it was in Parma
and 20 years later we are seeing news
stories about Blaise Matuidi and in France
we see these things happen
more and more in the stadiums.
How would you explain the lack of progress
in this area after 20 years?
Well, first of all,
when I played in Italy they were actually
making monkey noises.
I think that if things haven't changed
it's because there is no
real desire for this to stop.
And when I was
playing soccer in Italy
and journalists came to ask me questions
and often told me what I should do.
But I said,
"You must understand that I can't.
I'm not the one who can solve this."
The victim of racism isn't the one
who can find a solution.
It's everyone else.
And this is what I said to them,
"For me, it's very simple.
If the people who aren't
victims of racism right now,
meaning those who judge me
by my skin color,
the people,
the players who aren't black,
leave the pitch, believe me,
that would have a huge impact,
and that would lead to change.
Because when a black player
leaves the pitch
the game carries on.
The problem is that it's a business
because that's what soccer is,
it's a business
and they don't want
to damage the business.
So, no meaningful decisions are taken.
And I think, really,
it's not that difficult
to change, and to start with
we can find out exactly who
people are in the stands.
And so, it requires a political will
and the will of the club
to stop it, and I think it's
that will that's needed.
And I'll say it again, I'm convinced that
in order to change people's mentalities...
it's not the people
who are discriminated against
who can change mentalities.
People who are discriminated against
can strongly criticize
can meet up to talk,
but they absolutely need
people from the other side
who think it's unjust.
And what's interesting in our society,
I think that more and more people who
aren't victims of racism,
are intervening to denounce it.
That is why society,
I'm talking about nowadays, is better than
the one my grandfather
or my mother lived in.
Because I think there are a lot of
people who won't put up with it.
They don't wait to experience
racism before they condemn it.
homophobia before they condemn it.
There you go.
Thank you, Lilian, and maybe,
to pick up on that point
it's interesting to note what's
happened in the US this summer
with the quarterback Colin Kaepernick,
who wanted to make a strong statement on
the violence against black people
in the US.
And it seemed like there was
a certain amount of solidarity
from the owners of the
American Football clubs,
but, sadly the player doesn't play anymore
and it's...
It's a bit of a mixed...
result.
The question I wanted to ask you was
OK, everyone here knows about the
French team's victory in 1998.
in your opinion, is it still
a genuine political symbol
or is it a sporting victory?
And finally, is the type of
story they tell about this French team
in your opinion, was it just journalism
or do you think there was
real political impact
in what you did?
I think it had a genuine impact on society
first of all, there were questions
that were accepted more readily.
The year of the victory was 150 years
after abolition in France
so there as well,
people were asking questions.
And since then,
people have been questioning
French society.
And when people ask questions,
other people get upset.
But that's very important,
like your example of the quarterback.
He's not part of the club anymore,
but that's in keeping with history.
That is, people who intervene
to condemn injustice very often
pay the price.
But that's the same
in any group, isn't it?
Even here, if someone came along saying
"No, but listen, you need
to change what you're doing."
The first time, OK, the second,
the third time you say,
"Right, what's he doing?"
OK, because in any setting
you'd get upset.
And that's why we must teach
children in particular
to not be afraid of upsetting people.
Because the more people who get upset
the more things will evolve
because you can't get rid of everyone.
And at some point you have to listen.
And that's what's happening
in France at the moment.
There's tension in the air.
And in my opinion something
new is going to come of that.
And we need to break our habits,
every one of us,
and it's difficult to change our ways.
We don't want to change our customs.
And when we ask you
to give us more equality,
to question history, you don't want to.
Recently, there was this desire,
a petition that I signed
about...
Damn...
the guy who established the Code Noir...
Who was it? Colbert, thank you!
Colbert! But none
of the journalists understood.
"But what's it about? It doesn't matter!"
But if you don't understand the history
and if people didn't intervene
sometimes, who aren't afraid
of not being understood
you have to persist.
And that's it really.
You have to persist, and keep persisting.
To try to break through
the status quo to reach the next level.
Knowing that you are going to get
criticized because you won't be understood.
Because, for example,
there might be people in the room
who don't understand
what's being discussed.
Or, there might be people
in the room who don't understand
why you can't dress up as a black person
the way Griezmann did.
They'll say, "But that's OK."
If you can't do that anymore,
then you can't do anything.
You'll see, we can't do anything anymore.
Yes, you can do things,
but not like before.
And that's the difficult thing.
That's how the history of the world goes.
So, we have to keep
wanting to change things
and wanting to create more equality.
That's it.
- Thanks
- You're welcome.
- What's happening? It's going well.
- It's going well.
We have five minutes left
and two questions, right?
- Yes, two. I'll be quick.
- Perfect.
I would like your opinion on
political solutions
like they have in the United States
where they have quotas
which, on the one hand, sadly,
put some people in boxes,
and say, "OK, you are a minority, etc."
But, on the other hand,
create role models
and that can also change
people's mentalities.
They say, "OK, you can
be black and the president, etc. etc."
So, I would like to know what you think
of this solution in the United States.
Well, first, I think that
when we call it
"positive discrimination", in France,
that's not the right word.
Because, really, nobody
wants to be discriminated.
I think that perhaps we need to
describe its history and say that,
actually, we need to restore balance.
We need to restore balance.
So, obviously, most people
won't agree with that.
Why? Because, effectively,
they feel rejected.
And they aren't used to being rejected.
That means,
this young, dark-brown woman,
normally, if she understands
the society that she grew up in,
would realize that
there's a chance she will be rejected,
so she prepares herself, saying,
"Potentially, it could happen."
But really, I think that it's about
restoring balance.
Because historically, if you were a women,
you were discriminated against.
But something I often notice is
that people say
"Yeah, but even so, they
wouldn't give someone that position
if that person weren't competent."
But, that's not the real story.
Sometimes, you can be competent
and not get the position.
And if you're a man
you have the right to not be competent
and still get the position.
So the idea is to restore balance.
But I can understand why
some people don't want that.
But I think that it's very
important to change things fairly.
Because you obviously need a template.
Obviously.
Hello, you have spoken about
your work with children
what about adults,
is there a right age
for unlearning racism?
Really, there's not a correct age.
But it's more complicated for adults.
Because you think in terms of certainties.
And you have been
brought up in a particular way.
If you talk to your parents,
or your grandparents
they lived in a world
where there were certainties.
For example, we'll talk about the
relationship between men and women.
When you look at older generations
the hierarchy between
men and women is more marked.
So, that's why I say
it's sometimes difficult to change
older people, but that doesn't mean...
when we have exhibitions...
for example, we had an exhibition
at the Musée de l'Homme
where we explained—by the way there's a
film out at the moment, about Barnum.
- You know who he is? OK.
- Yeah.
- The Greatest Showman.
- OK.
You need to know that not so long ago,
we exhibited people in the zoo.
Black people,
Native Americans,
Orientals, as they called them, in fact
for many Europeans, the first time
they saw these types of people
was at the zoo.
But, maybe you didn't know that.
But that went on for a long time
and that created a culture of viewing
people as exhibits.
And recently, we went to
I think it was the zoo
in Cologne, in Germany,
and over the entrance
there were animals and humans.
Meaning, by walking through that door
you could see animals and humans.
In the Jardin d'Acclimatation in Paris
they used to have human exhibits.
By the way, I believe Christian Karembeu's
great-grandparents were exhibited there.
But, we are the products of that history.
So, the way we look at people
is significant.
It comes from somewhere.
And if they present
people to you as savages
you're going to believe it's true.
And that's a cultural thing.
And so when you come
across them outside of the zoo
you're going to be a bit frightened.
One thing I find remarkable,
that makes me wonder, is...
They say that diversity scares people.
Do you agree that diversity isn't scary?
Maybe you are, a little.
- Why me?
- I don't know.
It's because I'm in the front row.
But, they frequently say,
"diversity scares people."
But when you are at the station,
or on a train
you don't know the other people.
There are people who are scared.
Take me as an example.
When I was a young player
a very long time ago
with my teammates who had dark-brown skin
we knew that other people were afraid.
I don't know why.
I don't know why, because nobody had said,
"Careful, they're afraid."
But from the way they acted,
we knew that they were afraid.
We knew it.
Nobody had explained it to us,
but in our heads
we said, "they're afraid of black people."
Not you, madam.
But that's how it was, do you see?
And so, really, it's education.
And that's why I think we need to
focus our efforts
on children, because they
are less conditioned.
When I talk about certain
things with my mother
it's surreal.
When she was at school, they taught her
that her ancestors were Gauls.
I asked my mother,
"How could you believe that?"
There's a problem there, right?
She said,
"But, that's what we learned at school."
So, we need to question
the things we learn in school.
They might teach us some
strange things in school
even nowadays, right?
Christopher Columbus?
What's your ethnic origin, madam?
You shouldn't sit in the front row.
Central African?
Who discovered Central Africa?
Oh, you don't know?
It was Christopher Columbus.
Did you not know that?
It's an interesting example
to help us understand.
That's why I tell the story,
I think it was the
Treaty of Berlin in 1865
when Africa was divided up.
Had you heard of that?
OK, but that's interesting to know.
And the problems, the power relations
between Europe and Africa
still exist today.
We mustn't be naive.
These power relations still exist.
And, really, we need to question them
because I think these power relations
whether that's during slavery
or as part of modern colonization
come from a small number of people.
But that depends on the discussion.
The exhibition that we put on
about the East...
even today there's an element of fantasy
in the way we talk about the East.
Even we end up believing in it.
And that's the thing.
It's taking time to ask ourselves,
"Am I looking at the world
in the right way?"
But we often don't ask that question.
For you, coming from Central Africa,
it's not the same?
Right? What do people see
when they look at Central Africa?
Nothing? Really?
She's not answering me,
she's having trouble.
Another question.
Thank you very much,
it's 33 minutes past, I know you all..
Thank you.
We can do better than that,
it's Lilian Thuram, let's give it up!
Calm down.
I would like to thank you all
we thought there'd be
at least one question on soccer.
And it was all political.
We could have had a question on soccer.
I thought there'd be one,
but there wasn't.
- Ask a question about soccer.
Yeah.
- OK, soccer then.
- I have a question about that.
Go ahead.
Although, I'm not really into soccer.
That's OK.
- Me neither,
- What's it like to...
...to score a goal in the World Cup?
Against Croatia.
What did you feel in that moment?
Well, to tell the truth,
I think I was in a daze.
No, it's true.
Because I think
what people noticed
when I was on my knees and all that,
I think people were saying
"Hey, this guy doesn't know
what's going on, he looks lost."
That was the reality of it.
But, actually, what's really interesting,
when I talk about soccer,
especially to very young people,
is telling them that
it's important to have dreams.
It's really important.
And you can't achieve them on your own.
That's why I talk about self-esteem
and learning that
you are allowed to make mistakes.
And that you improve by making mistakes.
I know this is an American company
it's partly the culture: in
France, you can't make mistakes.
Because otherwise, and I think this is
what we need to encourage...
we need to tell children,
not to be afraid to make mistakes
because that's how you progress.
And most importantly,
you can't succeed on your own.
Because they tried
portray me as a superhero
when I scored, but it's quite the opposite
you don't win matches on your own,
it's not possible. There.
- Thank you very much.
- And, if you train
- You could also score goals like me.
- Erm, no.
- You haven't seen me play. No, no...
- I thought there was something...
Even as I was saying it,
I thought there was something.
But you're right, I'm terrible.
Anyway, thank you, Lilian,
thank you all for coming.
Thank you.